[Música]
la tormenta de Elliot continúa siendo
estragos en buena parte de Estados
Unidos provocando bajas temperaturas y
fuertes Nevadas 1,5 millones de personas
continúan sin servicio de energía
mientras que 4000 vuelos han tenido que
ser cancelados Se esperan que las
condiciones comiencen a mejorar a partir
del día domingo
la ciudad de gersón en Ucrania fue
nuevamente blanco de ataques de las
tropas rusas que dejaron hasta el
momento siete muertos y 58 heridos el
gobierno ucraniano liderado por el
presidente Apolo dimmir zelemski condenó
el bombardeo y lo calificó de un
asesinato sin sentido
las autoridades francesas dieron a
conocer los nombres de las víctimas del
reciente tiroteo ocurrido en París
frente a un centro cultural kurdo Uno de
ellos es un reconocido artista y la otra
es una activista de los derechos de la
mujer el tirador confesó la iniciativa
racista de su ataque en la capital
francesa
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
a esta hora vamos a comenzar en América
Latina los migrantes que esperan en la
frontera entre México y Estados Unidos
están allí debido a la espera de la
derogación del título 42 no solo están
allí desafiando a las autoridades de
ambos países que pueden deportarlos
ahora también deben hacer frente al frío
extremo que está golpeando a la zona
debido a la tormenta Elliot los
albergues están a máxima capacidad de
ocupación pero para ellos retirarse no
es una opción viable Valentina Torres
Sánchez nos cuenta más en el siguiente
informe
una fogata para animar el helado
ambiente de los hasta ocho grados bajo
cero que se registran en Ciudad Juárez
este territorio fronterizo de México con
Estados Unidos que cada jornada ve la
llegada de nuevos migrantes del centro y
sur de América que esperan el arribo del
27 de diciembre Ay qué noticia hice
sobre el artículo 42 el título 42 por
eso en estos momentos acá cruzado porque
dicen que lo que cruzan lo están
devolviendo nuevamente a México la
mayoría de estas personas viene de zonas
tropicales con climas cálidos o
templados por lo que no están preparadas
para el frío y aseguran que las fogatas
solo ayudan momentáneamente cae el día y
el viento helado también causa estragos
La tremenda el frío no no lo no se
aguanta aquí y este los de migración de
las cobijas que dejan que hicimos ir a
agarrar y no nos dejaron dijeron que no
que no podíamos agarrar que nos fuéramos
de ahí
la Navidad está a la vuelta y la
nostalgia embarga de estos migrantes que
no pueden pasar la fecha con sus seres
queridos No pues sí vengo con ocho ocho
y medio de embarazo y pues
la verdad pues sí está mal porque casi
Navidad y aquí uno aquí en vez de que
esté con la familia la comida escasea y
los más de 20 albergues que existen en
Ciudad Juárez están desbordados
hace tanto frío que la gente viene y me
dice que los deje pasar que se quedan de
pie que no necesitan un lugar en el
suelo para dormir que solo los deje
entrar
en principio el título 42 iba a ser
derogado el 21 de diciembre pero la
justicia estadounidense decidió mantener
la medida hasta el día 27 la
incertidumbre embarga a estas personas
que no contemplan volver a sus países
seguimos en el norte del continente
porque la tormenta helada helio continuó
causando estragos en buena parte de
Estados Unidos en plena víspera de
Navidad hasta el momento unos una como
cinco millones de personas están sin
servicio de Electricidad y unos cuatro
mil vuelos han tenido que ser cancelados
de acuerdo con los pronósticos las
condiciones Aparentemente comenzarán a
mejorar después de la Nochebuena Andrés
triviño nos cuenta más
una Nochebuena helada en Estados Unidos
el 60% de la población al menos unos 200
millones de personas han estado bajo
alguna alerta por la tormenta helada
Elliot las autoridades han instado a sus
ciudadanos a permanecer en casa
principalmente en la frontera con Canadá
asegúrense de hacer sus planes de
vacaciones para otro momento si aún no
está Unido con su familia Porque la
madre naturaleza lanzó el refrigerador
de la cocina hacia nosotros esta vez la
tormenta es causada por un frente de
aire Ártico desde Canadá hasta Texas
varios estados de la costa este como
Florida y Texas podrían vivir las
navidades más gélidas desde que se tiene
registros la congelación de la
infraestructura eléctrica del país ha
dejado a más de 1.5 millones de usuarios
a oscuras en cuanto al transporte las
carreteras han colapsado dejando al
menos 15 personas muertas en accidentes
de tránsito además la cancelación de al
menos 4000 vuelos impide que miles de
pasajeros se reúnan familias en Navidad
me retrasé aquí debido a la loca
tormenta a donde voy acabo de escuchar
que se ha inundado por lo que no es el
momento adecuado para que entre ahora
Así que no ha sido una visita fácil en
este momento en particular pero rezo
para que todo se calme
según los pronósticos del servicio
meteorológico nacional Elliot alcanzará
su punto más frío en la víspera de
Navidad y habrán mejores condiciones los
próximos días
vamos a cambiar de tema nos vamos hasta
Europa Porque mientras se cumplen ya
diez meses desde el inicio de la
invasión de Rusia al territorio
ucraniano un ataque precisamente de las
tropas rusas contra la ciudad de gersón
dejó un saldo de al menos siete personas
muertas y 58 heridos el presidente
ucraniano bolodimir selensky condenó
este bombardeo y lo calificó como un
asesinato sin sentido en plena fecha de
Navidad
un panorama desolador tras un ataque
ruso a la ciudad de gersón recuperada
recientemente por las fuerzas de
kievero
de aquí sacamos creo que a cuatro o
cinco pacientes gravemente heridos dos
de un hotel y dos cuadras más abajo la
mayoría de las personas estaban muertas
el primer ataque golpeó a los grandes
almacenes aquí el segundo golpeó el
mercado la gente dice que murieron más
personas allí y también un ataque cerca
de dos tiendas es una pena que haya
muerto gente
un funcionario del kremlin acusó a las
tropas ucranianas de montar el ataque
para inculpar a los rusos Ucrania se
recuperaba del bombardeo Invasor a gran
escala del pasado lunes Esta no es la
primera vez que Moscú ataca gersón desde
su repliegue a los márgenes del río
nipro por su parte el presidente
ucraniano boladímir zelansky publicó un
mensaje de navidad a sus ciudadanos el
mandatario hizo referencia a las
dificultades que traen consigo los
ataques rusos a la infraestructura
crítica nacional
[Música]
cantaremos villancicos con más alegría
que nunca para que sea más fuerte que el
sonido del generador escucharemos las
voces y los saludos de nuestros seres
queridos en nuestras almas Incluso si la
conexión a internet se cae Incluso en la
más completa oscuridad nos encontraremos
para abrazarnos con fuerza y si no hay
calor nos abrazaremos durante mucho
tiempo para calentarnos
o de nodo días atrás el kremlin dio a
conocer que a pesar de los festejos por
Navidad las operaciones militares no se
detendrían
y Mientras tanto en Francia ya se
conocen los nombres de las víctimas del
tiroteo que tuvo lugar ayer en la ciudad
de París en pleno centro de la capital
francesa entre las víctimas se encuentra
un reconocido artista y una activista de
los derechos de la mujer el tirador
confesó la naturaleza racista de sus
actos Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más
son los rostros de las víctimas del
tiroteo en el distrito diez de París
eminecara líder del movimiento de
mujeres kurdas en Francia según el
portavoz del Consejo democrático culta
en el país europeo cara había solicitado
asilo político en esa nación un pedido
rechazado por las autoridades otra de
las víctimas fue un reconocido cantante
kurdo mir perware identificado como
refugiado político había sido procesado
en Turquía por su manera de crear la
tercera víctima fue Abdul raman kisil un
ciudadano kurdo que frecuentaba el sitio
de los hechos Mientras tanto este sábado
la comunidad kurda salió a la calle para
manifestarse en contra del ataque y a
pedir más acciones del gobierno francés
para protegerlos
están tratando de hacernos creer que
esto es un asesinato racista que estos
asesinatos son cometidos por un hombre
mentalmente inestable aceptar esta tesis
está fuera de la discusión
el simple hecho de atacar el centro
democrático kurdo es un acto político un
asesinato político
también continuaron los enfrentamientos
con las autoridades del orden
el tirador un hombre de 69 años confesó
el corte racista de sus actos sobre el
pesan cargos de asesinato violencia
agravada y homicidio doloso
cambiamos de tema para cerrar vamos a
ver estas imágenes de la Ciudad de Belén
en medio oriente en donde fue celebrada
la misa con motivo justamente de la
festividad de Navidad para el mundo
católico la ciudad que tiene un
importante carácter histórico es
mencionada en la Biblia por lo que es
conocida a nivel mundial por ser el
lugar donde nació Jesús con estas
imágenes Nos despedimos en este
informativo de France 24 aprovechamos
para desearles una feliz navidad de
parte de todo el equipo técnico de
France 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]